hello earthlings
and people that get the internet
wherever you are it is
9 9 20 20. that's right september 9th
2020 and this is the reuben report
direct message
i give you two or three possibly four
stories
in about 24 minutes and then you move on
with your life that's how we're doing it
uh we've got a bunch today we've got
four although two of them i'm gonna kind
of package you're gonna watch me
package two stories into one story so
you can pretend it's three
but if you need it to be four because
it's technically four
that's for you to decide uh there's a
lot going on in the world
uh real quick before i start you know
when i decided to do this show and i was
talking
to the blaze guys about doing sort of a
semi daily news show and everything
one of the things that i was worried
about is as i always tell you guys i
don't want to just add to the craziness
make everybody angry and all that stuff
and i was worried that if i do a daily
thing and i've been saying this for
years actually i've said this
on my interview show for years and years
and in many other interviews
that one of the problems is everyone
does all of these daily shows where
they're like oh
i have to find 15 stories to talk about
then we got to clip them 800 different
ways we got to get everybody lost in the
algorithmic click hole of youtube or
just making sure that they're
watching our show for an absolute hour a
night if it's cable news whatever it
might be
and that that in and of itself keeps us
all sort of as the hamster in the wheel
and we're just running running running
all the time always looking
for more stuff and we never stop and
relax uh what i've found in just the
what four or five times that i've now
done this new direct message show
is that you can kind of pick a couple
things in the morning
that are decent that aren't going to
make everybody crazy and i think you can
do them
in in a pretty decent way so here we go
uh number one i think this is good news
i think if you're not
a partisan crazed lunatic you might
think
that this is good news donald trump
has been nominated for the nobel peace
prize
now that seems good because the word
peace is attached to it and
it would seem that maybe he did
something that was
pro peace i'm already seeing tweets that
uh you know that's
not the case this is this is the
ultimate insult
to the famed nobel prize which of course
barack obama got like the day he became
president even though he had
accomplished absolutely nothing that was
not a white power symbol by the way that
was just as
we used to this used to be like a just
zero sort of thing or okay
um but donald trump has been nominated
for the nobel
peace prize uh by a norwegian lawmaker
uh this is a guy
who's in a right wing party it must be a
scary right-wing party
in norway his name is tybrin getty i
believe i'm pronouncing that correctly
and he wrote in his nomination letter
that
as it is expected other middle eastern
countries will follow in the footsteps
of the uae the united arab emirates
this agreement could be a game changer
that will turn the middle east
into a region of cooperation and
prosperity so before i go any further
with what he said what he's talking
about
is in august israel and the united arab
emirates
signed uh at least some version of a
peace accord they're now having
travel between the countries and trade
and things like that there's an
absolutely incredible video
that i've seen on twitter i'm sure many
of you seen it too with benjamin
netanyahu the prime minister of israel
speaking to an official in the united
arab emirates
they're on the phone and they're
speaking hebrew they're laughing like
you can tell something decent is
happening here
we're also being told that in the last
couple weeks there's uh talks now for
several other countries maybe four or f
four or five other gulf nations to sign
deals with israel
i thought this is what everybody wanted
you know it's funny when i
when i came back on the grid and i did
my show with michael knowles
uh he listed out like the 20 things that
i missed and in a certain
respect we kind of glossed over uh
the israel arab country gulf country
peace agreements here because it was
like there was so much going on and what
he said was that well
actually the media kind of ignored it
and that in many ways gets to the heart
of what
is wrong with so much of what's going on
in the world right now it's like
if something that we all wanted right
like everybody i thought the thing that
everybody wanted the thing that can
never happen that we all
want is that we want peace in the middle
east nobody can do it and there's been
a million deals they've tried to have
and they've had agreements and they've
had accords and they've had
meetings and everybody's gone to camp
david and they signed things and nothing
ever happens
but now it actually seems that there's
been some sort of realignment in the
middle east it seems like there's been
some sort of
tectonic shift that alliances are
actually changing and maybe the old
wars of the last century
maybe they won't happen anymore because
countries are realizing oh that little
tiny piece of land the size of new
jersey that has no oil those guys
maybe they're not that all that terrible
but i thought that was something that we
all wanted and it's like if you look if
you just look right now
on what the pundits are saying it's like
either they're ignoring
the original deal with the uae and
israel
or they're trying to minimize it but
this norwegian lawmaker who i'm sure is
going to have a zillion hit pieces
written about him any day now
should be by the time i finish speaking
the sentence he feels otherwise he went
on
to say that that trump's key role
in facilitating contact between
conflicting parties
and creating new dynamics and other
protracted conflicts such as the
cashmere border dispute between india
and pakistan
and the conflict between north and south
korea as well as dealing with the
nuclear capabilities of north korea
all basically make trump worthy of the
nomination now that
does seem legit so let's try to remove
partisan
politics from this for a second and just
deal with reality
let's assume for a second if we're to
believe any of these things
that the middle east is shifting a
little more
towards peace that there doesn't seem to
be this feeling that is going to be
suddenly a war
breaking out there i don't think anyone
really feels that i mean there's still
some stuff when they're on but
i don't think anyone really feels
there's suddenly going to be a war i
think
part of that is that people don't know
what trump will do now his critics would
say oh that's because trump's crazy and
he's got his finger on the button and
the whole world could blow up tomorrow
in world war three
i think it's actually a type of strategy
that you go oh
you know we've got a pretty big army and
you don't know what we're going to do
with it
that used to be called deterrence right
that's what you get taught in political
science you have
deterrence you have a big army sometimes
you threaten people sometimes you don't
but you keep a little bit of elements of
surprise to keep your enemies
sort of on their toes so right now it
doesn't seem like there's going to be
any sort of middle east war he also
referenced that north and south korea
seemed to be heading a little bit
towards peace we've seen a little bit of
that right
we saw the very awkward walk that trump
took with kim jong-un i mean we've seen
that
something decent seems to be happening
there uh
the kashmir area between pakistan and
india
we haven't heard too much about that but
i don't sense that a war is breaking out
like it does seem that the world
is shifting a little bit maybe the days
of giant you know ground invasion wars
are ending and this will
actually get me to the to the next story
that i'm combining with this one
so this all seems good
right these are all the things that i
thought we wanted
and if barack obama can get a nobel
peace prize for doing nothing then it
sort of seems to me that yeah trump is
at least worthy
of nomination i'd love to hear your
thoughts on this though if you disagree
with me let me know in the comments
right down below
and this actually shifts me to the to
the second part
of this story when i said we had three
or four depending on which way you look
at it
uh this story is just breaking right now
but trump has announced
or it has leaked at least that there is
going to be a further
troop withdrawal uh in iraq
now again i think this is a good thing
right what did we want we wanted troops
out of iraq we can debate all day long
whether you thought the iraq war was
good
we can debate all day long whether they
were on the path
to democracy and then we pulled out our
troops too soon let's not forget they
were having
basically free and fair elections and
then obama did do what he said he was
gonna do which was just get our troops
out quickly
and then basically the country fell
apart again then we had the surge
okay uh it seems to me that at this
point whether you were for the war or
against the war
that we don't need a zillion troops on
the ground in iraq
it looks like only after this withdrawal
and this is all sort of happening right
now so some of this stuff could change
but it looks like after this withdrawal
will only have 5200 troops in iraq
that seems pretty good and we of course
you can debate well should we have 4 000
should we have 10 000 where are they
going to be deployed are we keeping them
in the gulf
we could talk about all of those things
but scaling back
from these wars i think is what the left
used to want right wasn't the left
always saying oh it's the conservatives
and the republicans and the
neocons those are the scariest uh that
are that want all the war
and yet trump is now pulling us back
from those wars interestingly tulsi
gabbard who i've had on the show who's
a democratic congresswoman from hawaii
and
a veteran she's actively in the military
actually
she was completely anti-war and she was
totally rejected by the democratic
establishment right she had a lot
of underground support it was very
obvious to me she had a lot of
underground support
during the the primaries but then in
effect the party just pretty much
ignored her and even
when she hadn't even withdrawn they
weren't putting in
putting her in debates and they did what
they do with time and again when they've
screwed bernie and they've screwed other
people
where they suddenly change what the
qualifications are to get in debates
and the rest of it so it's a little hard
to tell if you let's put it this way
if you think that the old idea of
republicans want
war and democrats want peace if you
think that's the prism that we should be
looking at these things then you're very
confused at the moment because i think
most people most americans uh
don't want war would like us to wrap up
these things
do it as responsibly as possible and
then
leave the land to the people that live
there so i think
that leaving iraq is good oh and let's
not forget he's also
getting us out of that afghanistan thing
which i
people don't believe this but the
afghanistan war
which started obviously after 9 11 which
is
it's the what the 19th anniversary of 9
11 in just two days from now which is
which is just incredible
and i'll talk a little bit more about
that i was in new york city uh during 9
11 and it was
uh well it was beyond imagination i'll
talk a little bit more
about that tomorrow um but you know
we've been
in the afghanistan war for about 18 19
years it's the longest war in american
history
it's hard to really understand that or
or even believe it when you say that
right because it doesn't feel like a war
like we don't know really why we're
there we were getting the taliban out
and what and then it just kind of went
on and went on
and went on and it went on for bush and
it went on for obama
and trump is trying to scale that back
these are good things that that's all
i'm trying to tell you whether whether
you like trump or hate trump
us you know i think partly what's
happened here is that so many people
make their decisions on whatever trump
thinks so if you love trump to make a
decision it's automatically good and if
you hate trump and he makes a decision
it's automatically bad you you can't
look at the world like that you know you
have to
be for something not just be against
someone
and i think too many people especially
in the media
do that so now you're going to see
people sort of jumping through hoops
to basically explain why leaving iraq
or afghanistan is bad you're going to
probably start seeing a lot of that
on msnbc in the left-leaning places
because they can't give
trump credit because what have they said
about the guy the entire time
that he's hitler and you can watch i i
recommend you guys try to find it
there's a video that i did
the day after the 2016 election we were
at our
our old place and we were building the
reuben report studio so i didn't even
have a studio so
i'm i'm i forget if i was using my
computer my laptop or my phone i think
it was off a phone
and i'm just sitting in the backyard and
you can actually hear construction
inside
and one of the things that i kept saying
was look everyone's surprised trump is
president
okay even if you were a huge trump
supporter you were surprised trump was
president
people are freaking out they're going
crazy people are young people that woman
screaming i mean all hell is breaking
loose but what you guys could do right
now
and this is what i've tried to get the
left to do for for a while is a little
bit of
self-reflection you might want to go
you know we've been calling this guy
hitler and
his supporters nazis and it's really not
what you're doing to them when you do
that it's not what you're doing to trump
it's doing it's what you're doing
to yourself because you can never be
like oh that guy i've been calling
hitler
and all those nazis he's around they're
actually starting to do good work
and i think that is why the craziness
gets ramped up
because you can't have people that for
three years were calling him hitler
suddenly go oh hitler's doing good stuff
this this is a
sort of a psychological trap that
they're that they're locked in at the
moment so anyway
i think there's a lot of good stuff
happening right here and
and we have to sort of get through the
brush to understand it
we are heading towards a place not to
say that there will be pure
perfect middle east peace but it starts
with some economic agreements it starts
with some travel
it starts with some phone calls and the
truth is
trump has something to do with some of
that stuff
getting out of iraq is good getting out
of afghanistan is good
and and we shall see if he wins the
nobel prize
and speaking of prizes watch that for a
segue
uh the oscars remember hollywood
hollywood used to be a place where they
made things called movies
and they made tv shows and other forms
of entertainment
and what they would do is they would
generally hire people who were
capable of acting in these movies or
writing in these movies
and they would then create something and
then we would go to the movie theater
or to uh turn on our television and we'd
watch these forms of entertainment
and perhaps we laugh or we'd cry or some
other emotion would pop up
and that's what hollywood was there for
hollywood is just a business people
like to think that hollywood is this
sort of uh
that it's this like obelisk or something
this thing that exists
and it has this perfect set of rules and
and that that
is what it is but hollywood is just a
business it's in the business of
entertainment and what are businesses
businesses are trying to make money
well unfortunately hollywood which has
been one of the prime purveyors
of wokeness they've decided to go fully
stupid woke
and uh now the oscars
are going to have woke points in effect
social justice has completely if you
thought that there was any version of
hollywood
that hasn't been corroded by all of this
nonsense well if
it's here people it's absolutely here
there are new
oscar standards uh to require
best pictures to be inclusive
so we're going to pull up an image here
and i'm going to read some of this stuff
it's it's just
it's absolutely incredible but of course
it's not surprising
so standard a which is about on-screen
representation themes and narratives now
you want to achieve a standard
a rating so that you can win the oscar
that means that the film must meet one
of the following criteria
a1 a lead or a significant lead or
significant supporting actors
and what they're talking about here is
that means that a leader or a
significant amount of supporting actors
at least one of the lead actors or
significant supporting actors is from an
underrepresented racial or ethnic group
now this includes asian it includes
hispanic or latin
x by the way no latin or latino person
says the phrase latin x that is
something only that social justice
warriors force them to do
and they don't know why and it's very
confusing usually
white lefties you've got to have black
or african americans
indigenous native american slash alaskan
native
middle eastern north african native
hawaiian or other pacific islander
or other underrepresented race or
ethnicity so that's just
a1 so now first off what we're saying is
you have to have a certain amount of
these types of people based on the color
of their skin or or their ethnicity
to uh to possibly get that coveted oscar
now this is uh what we would call
complete and utter nonsense
that if you were doing a movie about the
mafia let's say let's say you were doing
i mean i could pick any mafia movie but
the to me the the best is goodfellas
right so goodfellas
was about the mafia and uh it was about
the italian mafia
and it took place in the 80s and the
italian mafia had a lot of you're not
going to believe this italian people
around them and they were making the
gravy
and all that good stuff and killing some
people there happened to be a lot of
white people in the film
uh they were mostly italian most of the
actors
were italian not all of them uh but
there were mostly white people at home
you may remember
that um what's his name who's that actor
who is uh mace windu who's the actor
michael the actor mace windu what the
hell is the freaking guy's name he's a
huge actor
what's his name freaking samuel l
jackson jesus
come on um samuel jackson was in it for
about three minutes
okay now he happens to be black but i
guess that wouldn't be enough because
that would just be one black guy he was
only in it for a few minutes now
putting aside the stupidity of all that
you can already see everyone knows why
this is nonsense
do you want to judge your actors skills
or your writers skills or anything else
or anyone forget your actors or your
your writers anyone your doctor
let's remove the oscars for just a
second let's say you had a heart problem
and you're going for heart surgery would
you want the best doctor or would you
want the best doctor who happened to be
gay or latinx or latinx
sounds like a type of mutant or or
whatever it might be
is which would you want or and call me
crazy
would you not care about your doctor's
gender
or sexuality or skin color and if you
were going for heart surgery
you would just say hey can i can i get
the best doctor
do you are you good at what you do could
you do my surgery i
don't care whether you sleep with a dude
or not
that's what you want but but they have
dumb this all down and it gets dumber
people
let's just continue uh a2 so that was
just the rules for a1
a2 are about the general ensemble cast
at least 30 percent of all
actors in secondary or more minor
roles are from at least two of the
following underrepresented groups
women are women underrepresented in
hollywood if we took the entire
the entire thing that hollywood is all
of the movies all the tv shows are women
way less underrepresented usually you
watch a show there's some women in it
there's some men who's counting this
but you've got to have racial or ethnic
groups lgbtq plus i'm still a little
confused what the plus is
uh people with cognitive or physical
disabilities
or who are deaf or hard of hearing
so i guess kiss off blind people you're
not on the list sorry blind people but
deaf people
we're gonna get a whole bunch of you in
there you hear that uh
a3 is that the main story or subject
matter and this is of all the stupid
ones
this is peak stupidity uh the main
storyline
theme or narrative of the film should be
centered
on under un should be centered on an
underrepresented group this includes
women
racial or ethnic group lgbtq plus
people with cognitive or physical
disabilities or who are deaf
or hard of hearing this is stupidity
people
this is absolute stupidity oh and the
best part of all of this
all of these rules which apparently are
extremely important and they're going to
end racism and bring equality
all of this they're not implementing it
till 2024
because you know you'd have to do a lot
of stuff
to make sure that the stuff in the can
that's waiting to come out over the next
couple years we would they have to get
rid of all of that
old-school racist stuff that they're
about to throw on us
all the stuff that's waiting to get on
netflix and on hulu
it's it's just the height of stupidity
it's why
social justice which sounds sort of
right again if you don't think about all
of this and you just hear this oh we're
gonna have more gay people and black
people and latinx people
and deaf people if we're going to have
more of these people in everything
that things are going to be better but
just just doing it for the sake of those
characteristics that are
that are meaningless doesn't make it
better i will say one other thing before
we move on
um i i have a friend who's an extremely
well-known
sitcom actor or actress i'm not going to
say whether it's an actor or actress but
has been but is very famous and has been
in several shows over decades
and this person told me that in their
last show which only had a brief
stint because it did not go well that in
the writers room
they in effect decided that they weren't
hiring people based on whether they were
funny or not
this person's a comic actor or actress
that they decided they were gonna say oh
we're gonna we have to have one gay
person we have to have one indian person
we have to have
one black person one asian person etc
etc and that what you got in there
was that in effect it's not only did you
say that the number one thing
to write a comedy show is not to be
funny but you get a whole bunch of
people who then
have all sort of they use that identity
and then fight over what the story lines
will be and everything else and and the
last show that this person did was
was an absolute disaster and miserable
for him or her
so it ruins everything and it ruins
every institution it comes in
and it's it's ruining hollywood when's
the last time you saw something good i
mean all of us right now were trapped at
home and what happens
you're on apple tv you're on netflix and
you can't even find anything
worth watching i'm watching um chef's
table the barbecue edition
that's pretty good actually because
those people have skills and i don't
care
whether the guy who's giving me barbecue
is black or white or gay or straight
or a lesbian or deaf okay and one story
i'm gonna do
real quick uh cnn have you heard of that
former news network
um well they put a
they did a little piece like an hour
long piece on joe biden
and it was called fight for the white
house joe biden's long journey and you
know the guy's been in politics for 263
years so it is a long journey
and one of the things they did let's
throw up the image is they showed
an image let's show the original image
first they showed an image you can see
it right now
of joe biden with his son and they're
at a redskins game and his son is
wearing a redskins hat
now the redskins used to be a football
team you remember football before
everyone stopped watching
uh but cnn felt that that was too
offensive
apparently so they edited out
the washington redskins logo they didn't
mention that they did it and then they
aired
the photo this way without
the deeply offensive redskins logo
now this story the reason i wanted to
just hit on this real quick
it's not that important in the scheme of
things right middle east peace
perhaps more important but
this type of story where a news
organization decides to edit out
something
whether you're for the redskins keeping
their name or you're against it whether
you think it's offensive and usually
it's again it's white lefties who are
offended by this
generally not native americans whether
you're for it or against it or whatever
it is
it existed this idea that we can erase
history let's tear down monuments let's
edit out
logos on hats all of these things these
are deeply dangerous ideas they could
have show well first of all they didn't
have to show the picture at all so
someone
there was some thought process at cnn
where a producer
and an ap and an editor everybody got
together and they said okay this is the
picture of biden we want to show and
then somebody
in in the name of social justice said we
must edit out that picture of the
redskins because they don't exist now
because we're so tolerant we've got to
get rid of it and then they just said
okay we're going to do it we're not
going to make a
you know they could have made a
commentary on it they could have put a
little disclaimer something
but they do nothing and the point of the
story and why i wanted to hit on it is
when they do these little manipulations
you've got to wonder what the far bigger
manipulations are
so i thought it was a story worth worth
noting i'm sorry if we showed you the
image and you were
you were deeply deeply offended we
should have put a trigger warning before
the show
i will talk to my team about that and i
will probably fire at least
three people preferably white ones this
was the reuben report direct message for
september 9th 2020.